how's that yeah yeah we're all set chin
yeah we're all [ __ ] set same man
that's right little uh little jean
jacket some a denim a faded denim almost
the same color uh-huh he's yours crop
top like cat no yeah I should have you
should have I should have you should
have done that yeah
it's fed it's not so I'll guy with clogs
and I wondered how you would react to
that God get clogs on there like clogs
and I don't like Crocs near Crocs no and
I don't like Birkenstocks when they that
they bother me I don't like [ __ ] Burt
you know tried pushing the Birkenstock
merch on me was freaking my boy Andrew
Schultz tell me don't knock him do you
try them he goes they're coming back my
dumpy
I really goes they're coming back in
event I'm all I'm all set on [ __ ]
birth well those are the clogs that he
was wearing right there those those
dance goes men's professional for the
far left the one in not that one not
that one the next one that right there
right now come often will make your
[ __ ] drive faster than seen a pair of
Crocs well I think it's people who have
a false sense of security i if you're
walking around in that I feel like I I
just boxed yeah I feel like I don't have
any traction I might have to run away
from you a might have to run towards you
there's there's an issue there by the
way not giving him away 145 bucks for
[ __ ] harken stuff no Bergen stocks
are expensive that's full leather Crocs
are cheaper crotch you can put in the
microwave yeah yeah stretch out what to
form to your foot little cheat code for
you [ __ ] I didn't know that yeah
Crocs are yeah this looking crotch just
giving up yeah you know no chicks
[ __ ] any guys this men get older when
you get to be my age and older what I
notice is they start dressing for
comfort and they don't give a [ __ ] and
then there's the feud I mean times who
they [ __ ] ride it out and I
appreciate an older man who does might
so my hair the guy who does my hair he
is I'm sorry you're the guy on set yeah
on set okay yeah it's not set okay now
because because father times your barber
what does that mean oh you know exactly
no I want to know what all the time
gives you an
nice things off the top things are
starting it out the bad things are
thinning out on the table my head like
Friar Tuck and I understand other time
is thinning out your shirt I got a I got
a paint it he's gonna give you a nice
little birds nest up he's got yep but
we're daddy's gonna go ahead and get
himself another hair transplant I have
to classic okay surprise for coming here
with a full head of hair and beautiful
[ __ ] eyes with no skin whoo I love
that honor yep and then and a whole new
look
yeah but that might be Mason right there
that's that's the worse is when the guys
just don't give it up when it's just
like right here and he see a ball
they're like dude you just draw
attention you gotta have some vanity a
little vanity and fashion sense the guy
does my hair is a gay man but still he
his beard he wears a sweater a certain
way he's got he's got the earrings but
everything about him he is considered
it's all considered I that [ __ ] now
he's a married man
alright now you take it easy oh alright
man as a gay dude
yeah what's happen means married to is
yeah well two guys you guys who bros i
told you that you were married yeah I
mean you'll never marry like dude I saw
this [ __ ] guy on the bus and I just
you'd be like bring him home and I'll
wrestle him yeah in submission let's
spit for it go yeah well there is a
there wasn't this is so gay why don't we
always go get your gay here's that there
was a there was a Robin Bird had a
cable-access show back in the day and
they would have these hot girls on there
and stuff like that and like soft porn
and then they would once in a while have
like gay men and then they'd have a clip
of the movie that he would do there she
is and and the clip in the movie would
be and then this guy was in jail does
she aged like a blueberry
she's like a blueberry this guy was in
jail and this is the gay thing and he's
in there he said hey what are you guys
doing man that I hold him down he's like
no I don't want to and and he's like we
heard you're a dancer and he's like yeah
what about it he goes yeah you're
flexible and he was super flexible they
made him do the splits
one guy was holding one hand like the
other hat goes well do like I mean you
know what happened after that but I was
like I was member looking at it going
jesus [ __ ] christ
what is happening right here this is
terrible get this off right now but I
gotta finish watching it yeah but
sometimes it gets
he said when you and your it on that
pornhub there's this there you'll be
like what's that little rum nail did you
know what's happened I know this guy
with his dick Oh
like why are there two takes and my
brain takes a little bit to process it
like well there's one in the butt and
then yeah what wise was another giant
one hanging a lot like he's the tail
hanging out the front yeah and there's
tit
what's happening here what's happening
anybody does it yeah I'm like yeah have
you ever like seen strangers [ __ ] like
in a car walking by a car okay
I watched my friend [ __ ] it no yeah
that's about it
I walk by a car in Marina del Rey I was
walking my dog one night and I just saw
a big ass just going up and down the
cars beyond yeah was it dark yeah it was
dark was it with it with it with it
tinted windows yeah but all I could see
was that [ __ ] ass a big hairy guy
who's big strong my god that's a big ass
oh my god T's come on I couldn't get oh
and I don't want it I couldn't linger
because I didn't want to be I don't want
to invade their privacy now if you
haven't seen so one second quite some
time sighs on the tube yeah on the old
tube you never seen never look in a
window seen two people going at it never
this guy has hell yeah this guy who'd be
[ __ ] as I climb trees and keep on people
in a peeping tom
dude I was talking about this last time
like girl we were watching that Netflix
show called cheer you'll actually enjoy
it just from a sports aspect yeah you
don't realize it's the number one
cheerleading school i watch it oh I
loved it yeah good Matt talk
hashtag Matt talk what do you mean Matt
talk oh you didn't watch it that I
didn't watch it oh yeah well Matt Matt
saw as in as in are you gonna get Matt
time are you gonna be the one no no no
the one the one black we're right there
with a fat ass yes he's easier it has
wrestled with weight his whole life
athletic wrestled no he lost a ttle a
long time well he has but he's back I'm
hard-working yeah he's good at color for
the best mat tuck but he's not he's not
gonna make Matt but he has good Matt
tough he doesn't make Matt we're gonna
make Matt but it's so interesting like
then boys
just like a little sugar in the tank
then boys are sweet oh yeah this lolly
is it Oh what but why does cheerleading
just attract like such hardcore gay man
well I think you're super athletic it's
hot chicks but you're also great man
like it you're also kicking high and
going yeah a team now now I there's it's
not appealing to me I understand I want
to either play or watch the game of the
beer with my friends I don't want to be
out there going whoa and kicking and
doing acrobatics now here's why and
casting people here's why because I'm
wearing a uniform and I'm cheering for
my team now listen yeah and I'm gonna
ask you a question I did there I respect
them as athletes and that guy who's very
gay the taller one in the middle he'll
punch in the face he grew up fighting
okay cuz he had the H out his and he
played football playing fight I played
football now listen
he had brothers yeah sure the point I'm
making is this what's your point dude
they're very athletic guys and I'm gonna
ask you a question as you play football
right a little bit also what they're
doing is nothing yeah you understand
that so in other words it's not as
though this cheerleading team is so good
hey my team's gonna win because I think
what they're doing is very athletic it's
also nothing yeah it makes their you
right yeah when you were playing ball
and you're rid of real cats where you
play Ted in yeah sure now they're
cheerleaders on the side did you ever
look over and go you're a tired I can't
do this knee went it's [ __ ] gross
[ __ ] I'm gonna score this touchdown yeah
no I tell you this I even know I was
doing it so you know how there's like
they're all like all the gay guys are
roommates they're all black I even know
I was doing this but we're four episodes
in and I guess every episode I went I
look That's not me now we came in I
think to my girl yo do you think they
suck each other off all the time she
doesn't answer
next episode shows him again I didn't
know I do it might be CT
might be a gay male you think like
[ __ ] children hours she goes she
likes me she goes I have no idea sir DAP
so I go God you think they still like
when they get done like sucking each
other off like all that because they're
dudes the price of sucking each other
off ratios what's your
he'll what is this I want what she was
do you realize do you realize every up
so when they show those guys hang on the
dorm you asked for hooked I'll be
throwing it really she was young I don't
know why I would just if I'm a straight
man right if I was a straight man and
I'm around those hot chilies all the
time and we're around the dorms
I'm trying my I wonder maybe they're
just friend I don't know now let's say
we're both 21 yeah gay men yeah
flipping chicks all day you know you get
done we're all sweaty
yeah nice take suck and study I don't
know don't you think I don't I didn't
actually think that I didn't think that
yeah I didn't think that is you don't
think we're all hanging out in the
dwarfs the guy one now one who's amazing
watch it yeah that guy like Jared I like
it it's good that Harry season was good
how about how about the the one girl
who's really famous yeah the girl on the
left that did the real famous one Gabby
prepare yeah Gabby her parents are
suspect Oh her parents had no
opportunity hey they had her in that
that business from age of one yeah how
about their like and I know everyone's
like oh she came she met to get her
degree and stuff like that but she makes
more than a lot of people working 70
hours a week so okay I'm like I don't
like that's gonna last me yeah yeah do
you know what famous president was a
cheerleader
careful now what famous president was a
cheerleader Obama nope nope yeah yeah
not JFK's way to gangster for them
Reagan no Nixon no definitely no those
guys yeah famous cheerleader I mean
President was a cheerleader at Yale old
oh [ __ ] that's right Bush w.w was pull
that up see pictures of him gayer
yeah Bush was a cheerleader was his
Pappy orbit on Madonna's Pappy was the
real deal w-was ah BW he's all his tank
not really W was just a guy who was it
Wow various night states and say you
mind something yeah that's a well it's
dad and it helped that he was part of
the bush dynasty but I'll you think yeah
maybe a little bit
didn't really is he had a bunch of
businesses didn't really go anyway you
know that's fine when people I'll tell
you this USC scandal the celebrity yet
oh you oh you think Bush passed the
great think you had the great to get
into yeah oh no no no papa no no what
are you doing head cheerleader at his
high school
Oh head cheerleader at high school
oh no look I knew Nixon was a or no ya
know you're gonna make it was this
cheerleader well that's a little suspect
cuz Reagan might have been like part of
a rally right so I don't think Reagan
was actually an organized cheerleader I
think it was an actor's impairment who's
the parent guy who a good Matt talk
Reagan no I don't you talk Reagan I know
you're bad Reagan no see I don't know
say yes with mr. Reagan mr. pres what's
crazy is there there tell me how those
girls get CT to how they get concussions
oh [ __ ] yeah they get really bad
injuries hey what hey you know the
director was like I want you know cuz he
did the last chance you got coach dude
he's like cheerleading is the toughest
thing I ever had to film you stop it
right now
yeah you sign I know you selling this
documentary and I what they do stuff
yeah it ain't college football no but it
is true that the girls who tumble gets
dropped a lot they get [ __ ] up yeah
they break because they did it Sports
Illustrated a thing on how what kind of
injuries they were getting no like blown
they're kind of crazy ankles oh yeah all
that [ __ ] that one died a b-girl has
that's good and I did a sycophant bar
huh cuz she's she's originally from
Florida I just kind of assumed that
maybe she like just has bad genetics and
then on top of that hands a lot I get a
kick out of when I hear athletes talking
overhead which I just did you and I just
heard a couple athletes talking we're
all we were talking to an athlete do you
see what I talked about like the remem
deep in those deep in those circles and
deepest deep so what about you you've
been very good about your beauty
you know what you're a good vault you're
a vault you keep your mouth shut you
don't even really tell me you'll just
look at me if you ask yeah you're like
no when you go you think that got ya
yeah you just go but I was there I was
well I know someone who sold it do I
know a coach yeah yeah yeah I mean
especially back when you were fighting
and before you sada all the Golden Age
was he talked about the good days and
we're talking about mm uh yeah yeah but
it's like Gabby girl I'm like I wouldn't
put it past those stage parents to
[ __ ] inject some anavar in her ass
how old is she now is it cool if I find
her attractive or yeah she's definitely
or she 18 she's old enough and she's 22
year olds 22 are we good baby she's hot
yes she is
he's hot yes she is the rest of them I
think great gotta be hot hatch got an
intensity to her to look at her
give a [ __ ] look if he seems so sad
throughout the entire thing though
something's going on there a little bit
of depression her parents she's a
celebrity hottest [ __ ] he probably knows
it it's like where's this go right now
well uh oh you want me ask ya how her
movie ends she opens up a Jeanette
school cheerleading school and then
hopefully he gets that's right she's 22
though it's all gravy but she's bad dude
good math talk find anything good
Matlock she's an athlete that back out I
get mad dog man yep yep you like you
like what did you Cheerilee can i feel
like you know about it cuz I'm Asian no
cousins aren't good at cheerleading yeah
those two deaf what were you squatting
by the way I have another about 245
that's that's no job Ryan let's be real
I don't think I could squat 245
no bubble no I'm sad I'm gonna try and
be funny that's mourn Brian what I can
do
yeah super impressive yeah I was kind of
some cheeks at the patient's watch heavy
was 225 and it was [ __ ] heavy I know
listen you got a squat and deadlift get
it some cheeks I've been very busy but I
have a great ass you're not bad
all right you have a bubble but I got a
bum
but I am not strong when are you when I
got a deadlift
remember I got embarrassed when I was
dead lifting 145 and you and Tim Tebow
walk it was super embarrassing and I
stopped and put down the weight I don't
get embarrassed about anything I was
like ooh I don't seem well enough and I
felt skinny yeah I don't feel good
around I'll stop that I like that
respect there you yeah but I didn't how
muscles are twitching right now man look
Mike Glenn's been come over the house
you trained at the house
I'll get mitts for about 45 minutes and
we do some circuit training Jesus I know
man
it borders man I just been there too
long I don't know yeah well you change
it up enough yeah I'm always on that got
you even do peloton before he comes over
you're out you work out along attracted
to the peloton girls but what you say
what you said that outer corner mouth
bro no man I was aggressive I know yeah
you look heavy right haha hey how was
last night at the store I didn't go
Brennan I didn't go I told you we need a
bread we're doing too much we're doing
too much June times my third show today
I'm doing too much I have three shows
yeah I might have pain my dick uh-huh
shot that campaign and here's the thing
there are horses now when you shoot with
horses I installed a soul for money I
did I might it might be over for me it
might be over for me it might be over
we'll see but we were shooting with a
racehorse a real [ __ ] had to gallop
past me very close to me as I was really
shooting with that and in Simi Valley oh
that's why you guys ain't given Simi
Valley yeah in Simi Valley so yeah and
then you get this horse and they're
always unpredictable you understand then
you get a stunt guy who's whose horse it
is and he was way too into the yes now
the guy who was riding the guy was
riding was a real-life jockey yeah and
he's a he's a jockey gay man they are
100 pounds they're way about 115 yeah
their time and they suck wait just like
fighters so if they can be scared it
what a weird gig it's so weird to ride
horses they suck all that waiting
they're little people
so weird this so there's a lot of drugs
in the old junkie and in the job oh yeah
no no in the horses but not in actual
small jocks oh there's so much dry
they also sleep with their horses they
sleep in the bunk next to their horses
you understand the weirdest gig in the
world dude it's very weird they live
they do ever try to the jockeys they
sleep with the horses they sleep next to
their horses that's rooms men sleep next
to their horses it's a very interesting
insular world big money remember it's
that it's the gig sport of kings sport
of kings but it's all sunk in the day
it's also people who will sell their
plasma for extra money so they can
[ __ ] battle horses so you get you
know and then by the end of the race
they were telling me by the end of the
race five six my woman who was there who
owns horses said by the end of the race
at the Kentucky River anywhere else
people are so drunk it's just a bar tree
oh they come in they're all dressed up
well and by the end of it everybody's
like what the [ __ ] Wow you know it's
great so it's a jockeys take with them
at four or four ten ten inches
Wow two five feet six that's the height
limit five six four ten be tough to get
chicks what are you here for ten they're
genuinely tiny [ __ ] my best friends a
horse yeah 105 writing this thing every
[ __ ] most jockeys where summer
between 105 and 119 yeah and a guy was
something to us from Venezuela and a
very small man nice moment had been he
rides every day he races pretty much
five days a week you married to the
horse yes in doing it since he was a
little kid not a [ __ ] job they he loves
it they love horses he loves I mean
going fast different type of dude you
know yeah I don't know I don't know it's
a strange things you everything about
being jockey
I mean just a question bro you're a
tough guy yeah yeah you are
never thought about being jockey never I
did your dad been training more I have
push I'm a train more and a lot of
people saw what you did to me over here
and I don't know I'll take some [ __ ] I
don't report because I didn't fight back
by your sense they would you some [ __ ]
and I didn't fight back and you you
didn't take away your black belt that's
what I was hoping for my my training has
been upped even though I've been busy
yeah I feel you give him a train he's
been working so much but there are some
things that I know now that I would
never let you do so when I get my under
hooks on you
I've been making a crucial mistake you
will never ever do what you do me when I
get our notes okay bro okay
I'm not saying I can beat me up oh yeah
but I'll fight back and I'm gonna keep
you busy all right man get your hand on
my face probably treat you like your
jockey I'm not a jockey you're my jockey
I'm the big boy you know I have nobody's
[ __ ] jockey and I'm sure he's [ __ ]
dude you're my jock don't touch my hand
dude Josh you know the main horse's name
was big brown this is my era fake them
big brown you're the jockey no it's not
my times big brown one too [ __ ] that
jock yep
Hey yeah you fight I know in your jockey
dude have you heard of mr. hands yeah
you're looking at the horse of mr. hands
you're the guy that gets [ __ ] you're
the guy who's [ __ ] icing icing icing
dude you know what that means my [ __ ]
ass dude [ __ ] around yeah you're right
tap tap let me feel it wrist control no
no no you know where's you sensing that
though okay
I'm just gonna do this I'm gonna hide as
long as I can
here we go Hey wearing this how hard I
squeeze your hair that was a really hurt
yeah more tennis lessons I'll call that
a tear that's a draw dude it's a troll
yeah I tapped because you were cranking
my neck only cuz I couldn't see the
whole hockey move I don't like that neck
crank ooh nasty you get me here and you
do that you can't break a neck Wow
however I dude there's only one way to
find out but I feel like you could break
your hand by squeeze in it I I'm so much
tougher than you think hey you know 70%
we go hundo yeah I'm sure nothing like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] circle I honestly don't
think so dude that hurt I have [ __ ]
finger marks yeah look at my finger
monster oh my god indentation I'm round
I really done that 70% dude I was on
high middle that's 70 a hundo
I'm breaking it was like Chiclets son
you're a bag of you are a gorilla you're
weird strong to you well you you you
beat some big guys up well that's a bein
quote your big guy for you my next
little tweet go home and really that's
our god I hate when that happens
guy tweet Jays neck too in San Jose and
then I say nothing's more annoying than
Jays like this huh hey just leave me I
just got over a tweet next on the other
side this is on this side I've never had
it this side you gave me a new injury
this is what happens when we don't hang
out we don't see each other around you
act your friends you give you lose me
I'm gonna lie that's why you see a
little froggy you should bring more
actors in here I got a little froggy oh
oh your shoulder hurts I shouldn't know
I was doing this I'm just warming up
doing another [ __ ] round I'm gonna
rip your wig off listen I'm fantasize
about taking her scalp like that I would
I would fight you and I'll fight you now
dude I'll tell you don't want to give me
room here I don't
I can't do I don't need room dude I
don't have any room yeah your your your
your [ __ ] doing your [ __ ] jujitsu
when you I'm not you know I'm not even
responding you're not getting my neck
again I'll tell you that much
yeah I'll tell you what man these
jockeys fix your [ __ ] hair jockeys
stupid look my hair is dyed is it [ __ ]
us how did he get wide meet some water
you see what happens
yeah she was a jockeys little cocky no
don't call me a jockey [ __ ] strong
I got a tight green shirt on too I only
tapped that quickly cuz I'm afraid I'm
gonna hurt my neck yeah I don't know
dude don't ever [ __ ] my head up again
cuz the only problem in jujitsu get
caught on the neck thing you can't have
long hair did you do it why not
talk to the tea city banks differ well
you right but he rises in cornrows I
refuse to do that no I don't do to
anymore anyways listen jockey know your
place um yeah
big news everyone it's finally happening
this is the year where people are
starting to straighten their teeth and
you don't notice what they're doing
because they are wearing candid clear
aligners you don't have to go I had to
do it I went with another company I had
to go to the dentist I had to do a mold
I'd do all kinds of crazy stuff this is
not how it works first of all you get
these aligners delivered directly to you
and I straighten your teeth for 65% less
than braces would cost that's the first
thing on light braces Canada aligners
are comfortable and removable totally
invisible as I said and you can
transform your smile basically without
anybody noticing a thing plus here's the
craziest thing you never have to set
foot in a doctor's office or a waiting
room I don't know how they do this
frankly I've no idea
it's described remotely by a licensed
orthodontist and can it delivers
everything you need right to your door
or six months you can start getting some
straight teeth so you guys ready to take
the step towards straighter teeth yeah
hey you can get started seven dollars
off by using the code fighter at
candy-coat comm slash fighter that's can
decode coms last fighter use code
fighter for $75 off tena koe comm slash
fighter and then through a complimentary
3d scan of your teeth at a canada studio
near you
maybe we talk a lot about physical
fitness what about what about mental
fitness - I've got dude I got a mental
gym up here I was doing some heavy
squats yeah by heavy squats I mean I was
using that calm I'm talking about mental
fitness calm the number one app for
sleep meditation yeah sometimes you got
it just you gotta say you know who else
digs it Oh LeBron James there you go
ever heard of them of course do
sometimes we're both Type A
personalities we go super hard sometimes
you want to be calm and there's a nap
you got a com.com slash fighter
you'll get 40% off comuter show me a
Michelle a dude just talking about it
god I'm so good for your sleep good for
meditation
hey here's gotta find time for the
valuable things you can do if your body
and your mind yeah yeah listen my boys
know yeah yeah listen LeBron James it
tells you sleep is an important part of
his MO is stress you can learn how to
lose your stress I'm not stressed right
now me neither listen a voice hey listen
yeah if you get this app we score 60
points an NBA basketball game maybe but
you're not gonna know yeah it works you
probably won't
I don't know comms not gonna help you
square that mental notes in it to your
old man listen this yeah you might be
able to play at Duke after listen listen
you can buy a fish tank and stare at all
day or you can get the app calm yeah
listen it takes you through all kinds of
meditation stress relieving exercises if
it helps you sleep I have friends I have
family members that turn us away
we're by this turn on the right turn on
the rabbit leaves shut your stupid eyes
how about sleep stories how about
meditation yeah for a limited time you
guys can join LeBron and you think calm
cuz because we know you wanna became a
40% discount it be like LeBron give him
a 40% discount to an annual membership
LeBron calm calm / fighter unlock
content to help you focus ease stress
and sleep better hey listen if it works
for LeBron you just gonna work for you
that's right score points in your life
mentally and physically with calm I like
the analogy listen
slam the ball home in life
with calm with calm that's right steal
the ball of life in calm with calm ha ha
Phil Jackson on this coaching points
with calm you were gonna put me to sleep
with your drone monotone voice I'm so
tired dog this boy get started at calm
calm / fighter that's calm calm /
fighter I don't know any racists like
actual racists I really don't like
racists like like a real one I last one
it was my grandma you know it's just
that's what they tell ya now like now
that would be weird right yeah what are
you talking about I feel like I only
know racist people like racist Asian
people but they're racist towards other
Asians III know I know I know
hmm I know pretty girls who are they're
not black but they have black friends
and they're racist towards white people
yeah I don't see the word from that you
know more that's whoa whoa whoa whoa
that's a react white privilege like
super woke yeah my god take it easy I've
had some arguments with that yeah what
you say as you say I'm explained to me
why I'm Nigerians and West Indians have
a very different experience when they
come to this country yeah I can't just
leave it alone and then I always do that
to them I go I just don't agree with you
they're black either to West Indians
either Jamaicans a lot of times they
don't agree with I don't engage in that
whenever we have a talk about it oh
really
it's one of those tell me that white
supremacy is everywhere I was like
ridiculous I gave her some food talk it
was interesting I think Chinese Chinese
Asian people suffered a tremendous
amount of racism tremendous and that's a
fact and I can I can end violence and I
can give you the chronology but they
found their way through and a lot of
times you have to talk about culture and
Chinese a Jew
yep Jew same thing Chinese would come
and they would be and I'm sure the
Vietnamese I know the Koreans are it's
like you frugality and get really good
at something your kids are gonna [ __ ]
learn how to do
Tomic fool all of it yeah cat do you
ever experience any racism I bet you
would if you're dating a white dude or a
black well no I think if I was dating
white like if you and me walked into
like soap like a restaurant in Hollywood
hmm
I feel like it depends on what area
you're at like I know if I hang out with
like a white friend or a black friend
and I'm in a like predominantly like
Asian area we get more stares from other
like older Asian people yeah oh because
you're with a white guy yeah cuz I'm
with someone who is agent would you get
more stairs with you or with a white guy
or a black I think generally it would be
a black guy but if I brought like a
white dude home I would get more stairs
than if I brought a black dude home hmm
sometimes I'm in arrest I like a black
dude like this might be a real hot girl
I think of that my head I like the
mixing of all about dudes but human
beings are often cuter than a mix kid oh
so try were mm-hmm so cute I like I like
that's my favorite thing I feel like the
world's getting along better when I see
that Tiger had a way still does he has
pneumonia so as long as were weak when
his real little and they have to do an
x-ray and hold him down
this doctor I told him it dude I know
you're trying to help I'm telling him it
this ain't happenin brother they seen
happenin what you've had him out here
for and he's I'm talking fighting
shouting and they get it took two grown
men to pin him down and they're getting
that trace and I thought did I get him
he's hanging on me and shaking is good
man and they go oh we didn't get our
then you ain't getting it homeboy this
I'm Tony ain't happening yeah I'm
telling it's not happening and that Papa
Bear instinct it take that out honey now
it's so deep it's so [ __ ] deep it's
weird what he has to get it though right
to get your thought no the one that this
other female doctor was like now
wouldn't he all see has it you guys when
you keep doing this over and over
yeah but call a pediatrician I can't so
that's good that's always good yeah
she'll figure it out should navigate
through that they say revolutions happen
when people get too hungry or when the
dictator starts killing their children
that's when people are Nestle is okay
we're gone that's it you want to create
a [ __ ] stone-cold killer and me do
that it's like they're theirs is that
they were talking the story about this
African dictator camera the country was
but he was a [ __ ] [ __ ] and these
school kids threw rocks at his car and
he they he killed him he had them he had
the children that that's cool
taken and they think they that last
threw them to the crocodiles no and but
that was the beginning of the end that's
when people were like ah okay are you
gonna do that to our children
I feel sick yeah well it's like white
mighty whitey bulger you know the movie
Black Mass when he lost this suddenly
they said he was obsolete gangster he's
gonna make bad moves but once his son
died it was some sickness they said I'm
gonna start killing people after right
like just thank you they said that was
John Gotti they said God he lost his
brother Yeah right yeah I was son he
lost but he I think it was his brother
when his brother yeah I remember
there's certain things some things just
changed him yeah you just go oh because
it you're already a bad guy but you're
holding on because you love things that
so when you love things you don't want
to go you don't want to go to jail you
don't you don't wanna [ __ ] it up it
keeps you kind of optimistic about the
world but then when that's taken away
from you the monster comes out yeah tell
me something tell me something boy go
back in No
what's that are we back in now we've
been in back in back in since yeah you
weren't recording all that oh yeah sure
I'll talk to you after the back end
since after since oh well yes tar about
almost some will see that movie 1917 I
hear good things oh great I watched you
have you seen that show you Chris I know
it yeah I didn't see him because I'm
only on do you know what the shows about
dancing yep very interesting idea what's
it about
I lied I didn't want to hear it III
don't wanna ruin the surprise but I
could give me the premises it is he's a
you here's always over he's a stalker
you hear his voice oh yeah cool guy
Dexter
maybe okay Chris is in it as a pedophile
right uh second season I got a spoiler
though I gotta see that - it's good
now people love it man Chris just saying
out all the things he's done in urban
hit up more by this guy you know it's
interesting it's interesting
yeah I'm really into web cheer I still
got two episodes left on that chair
finished have you there cheer I know
that that Will Sasso one is his girl are
into 90-day fiance were you talking
about that idea Fiat they can hold for
me now but thousand pound sisters is my
[ __ ]
yeah finished there in Hernandez docked
yeah have you seen that yet no what you
think what what what do you think I
think you played quarterback in this
high school
this is quarterback to you you tweeted
that are you Instagram that his
quarterback was Jay it's chaos his lover
so they were lovers
yeah so he was a gay man I think
bisexual yeah [ __ ] guys though I know
that's all he said she's did you ever
get a vibe from him I never met him no
no tell us something or do you on me no
I'm you cuddled back go out for that
passing run a good round I'm gonna throw
it in the air
yes sucked on your sister on know your
Gernon war it's a love you I don't I
don't know if he's I don't know if he's
gay because put that I excuse me sir
he's not gay sir he's like what the [ __ ]
sir my duck who the the quarterback hurt
or go in there and it's earned he but he
was no we don't know we don't know he
never he never admitting no I think
we're there's that much smoke right the
only smoke is this dumb ass high school
Corbett is nothing going on
he said they were lovers yeah didn't you
have another guy or was that that was
the guy not and then he died then like
his prisons mate came out yeah we were
[ __ ] - like please please no major
snags yeah that's a big strong boy get
some current events try to that's yeah
that's any possible student Corrado
Vance I don't see mu tell me something
boy Oh tell us something girl you seen
the girl park
how are you happy in this modern world
oh do you need mu is this something else
you're searching for um fall in here and
all the good times I've found myself no
me man shut up shut the [ __ ] I'm
supposed to see the part L is something
boy I can't the high look I know though
can you sing that I know I don't
remember how it goes exactly like wow
that's a hard hey jokky can you do that
part let's see if Jing can hit that oh
no it'll be impossible
oh no that's till you sing it like oh
who do you want the girl was the [ __ ]
turds right there so I'm gonna tell me
something boy aren't you tried tired
trying to fill that void take your time
or do you need a mom yes I do ain't it
hard q I hate this line yeah I think it
runs a song it is hard ain't it hard
keeping it so hard gold it's hard to be
yeah then what a weird that's such a
weak layer I keep it hardcore though did
your hardcore
hey jokky shut up um dude imma tweak the
other side
[Music]
if I stand up well this is nothing this
is not a No
[Music]
you remember well I don't have a [ __ ]
Mac why did have time sprawl
Oh still there it's still there
861 what's your bottle each other I'll
be there soon
damnit tweaked my neck I warm up feel
like you wonder funny right get tired
you've been doing that
got some speed I still there still there
you know y'all dumb crazy had double
legs that disaster alright don't don't
drink with you oh this right she'll turn
it we're scrapping bring that back in
look I'm mad about that well I heard by
here was mascot what man I took it to
another level
yeah hey strong boy yeah that's I had to
pick you up in a strong twirl you around
good math talk okay good math talking
yeah you are a [ __ ] gorilla Brennan I
didn't do it I didn't do the things I
wanted to do that wasn't aware I know
it's if you like squish so you're not
getting you know yay please contact her
Gracie stop spraying the Gracie Academy
horrible Boulevard 97 0 I didn't even
I'm not gonna sprawl with a [ __ ]
couch there I hear you how did you think
I wanted to double it you into the cam
you're not getting is doubling [ __ ] no I
don't want to do that mmm you're not
getting the double dude I can't wait to
go to Matt to America I will move that
table he's not allowed to can't pick me
Evan slam me you know you can't be
picking people up and using their
strengths yeah you're right about that
pass
technique and strength you hop good luck
yeah you're not doing any post by the
way all over the wall he'll do that to
anybody any black pot you know
it's gonna say man can come see we just
stand up and Charlotte okay Saturday
I'll be a Cleveland will be seeing any
of that in a week Thursday show still
has some tickets left ursday Friday so
Charlie how many zones Palm Beach
Valentine's Day February 14 15 16 the
Valentine's Day I'm in Ontario okay
California good let's do some great
events for the vets all right I just got
a box awesome from bespoke all right now
what's it include let's see I got double
hitter I got shampoo and conditioner oh
man I got construction paste Wow I got
baseline grooming daily fresh bar I got
toothpaste with mint ice blends are in
them awesome stuff I get that's what
happens they send you stuff you get
started to take your quiz at box of
awesome calm your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month a
month across a ton of different
categories Wow it's free to sign up you
can skip a month or cancel anytime dude
that's crazy now how much you got a box
of claw this by the street I'd say this
box has gotta cost $6,000 oh all right
yeah or 500 bucks yeah you're getting
closer okay tries just 45 $45 but they
have over $70 worth gear inside today
and get 20% of your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of austin.com
enter the code F 80 K fat K at checkout
that's box of awesome calm code fat K 4
twice in off in our first box
sure here we go okay you asked us to
bring this up this is insane so hard let
me let me know Kate the Boomer here
today was a long day
for sure just be called Deonte but
delante Wes he's being the NBA was a
stud NBA player he played an all-star
game this is what he's doing now
so show Brian a picture will make their
film 4dos how long you play for one time
now the real athlete legit my baller
yeah and be a baller play the video for
her
so he's in the middle of a street laying
down have they showed that the L so you
oh [ __ ]
who is that some random guy right Oh
taking it Ellen from my truck
oh this isn't the video al-sabah oh my
god
that's terrible I've seen a video of him
on the curb yeah there's another video
so this these were videos of right
before you go home ah yeah that's
terrible is that a cop doing that - no
it was a random guy apparently they knew
each other and they got into a verbal
argument which led to a physical
altercation but this Delonte West has
been suffering from mental health mental
illness so a lot of people are just like
do this is so sad and you know that you
know who post the video who the cop
Delonte West talking he got fired
another video surfaced he's got mental
health issues back it up
why'd you hit that he attacked you first
with the top defenseman did you hit him
man I won't get straight they approached
me when I was gone god is he wearing
that new easy season port these
obviously schizophrenic
something's wrong for sure
I'd love to be schizophrenic sad that
crazy yeah well I think he's got ill
nasai think he's ill like somebody who
has cancer yeah you know I mean I think
we have to have compassion review like
that call terrible as that yeah not
heartbreaking nobody chooses to be that
way no one I would try a little meth of
get me a skinny I'm just being honest
with everybody here wow what a bummer
though that crazy look at Obama what is
done yeah and then and who knows you
know he may have it see so a lot of
people when they're in the 20s and 30s
men will become schizophrenic and they
don't know why yeah I'm getting you lose
your mind you're not crazy
hmm yeah officer spells just better not
fired I know you said why age do they
get her Brian between 20s at well teens
late teens 20 serda right
oh listen no that's his family oh this
is Twitter needs to take down that video
Delonte West people Meghan it counts
because social media makes everyone's
life feel like you're vegan this is real
life in a real serious issue it could
affect you remember the man with a
family your that's [ __ ] terrible
eatest kid and his wife is gorgeous
delicious yeah he's just not he's not
well he needs help and I feel the same
way about Antonio Brown after I looking
at that video
I think Antonio Brown has major seat
something's wrong we think he has a
brain agree I agree with you after that
yeah I think he has a brain but also
people are guys a piece of [ __ ] well he
he's sick he's not well yeah people need
y'all say people need to put some work
in with Dante West man so much teammates
there like that yeah also these guys up
on Twitter her like dog duo aren't they
were thinking he's on Twitter gain on
Twitter looking for math Lurie he's
dealing in the streets so don't tweet at
him [ __ ] find him and help problem
man Harper sent me cuz he's gonna end up
dead but he has kid that sometimes dad
yeah I like how these people are like
stepping up for him though you know it's
true could be anyone keep your dad's
sister but the people making phone my
god look you fell off breath Jesus
Christ men know a lot of us has done
more than 99% here in this [ __ ] short
NBA career
yes I've ever done exactly do I need
some help
what else you got there you go okay so I
don't know if you guys have heard about
what's happening here but watch this
clip first then I'll explain the cop is
trained to tell the players to put out
their cigars while they're in the what a
[ __ ] if they won the national
championship mm-hmm
what a piece of [ __ ] and then Oh BJ was
having some fun and he's not gonna
pursue charge but as that security guard
kid you [ __ ] kick rocks nerd the
kids'll come on they just want the no
guy probably happiness yeah so
originally he wanted to press charges
and I think a couple of days after the
story got out he got a lot of backlash
so he decides to drop it
so now obj is no longer gonna be facing
any battery charges or he got slapped in
has everybody be calm down I just got
choked out and I'm gonna see you ask for
the records you know what it's on video
now and I feel like you record show dude
no I I was in self-defense
you called me Jackie and I got me in the
face I got it you slapped me in the face
I did stuff unit but two wrongs don't
make a right then you messed my hair up
and this job worked on this mate wrongs
make one right all right so you're right
you know you were in the right nevermind
I'm not gonna press charges I thought
about it and now I've really I've been
looking for a reason to test where I was
that with my double leg no no no
sometimes I get too much energy like
when I one time I was like it's rough
house Sunday and I kept I kept poking
Brennan no I've slept and he goes rap
and he goes like this and he goes
alright and he started taking us watch
often I got scared I tried to run away
from stuff the Rolex man he caught me I
was intimidating and then Brett Rogan
got so mad at me cuz a pool cue I was
swinging that he didn't even knows it's
a $6,000 pool should we made for him
brownie made it for him it's like I've
Rihanna wears a bone and ivory is bone
human bone
yeah the fiends human bones of feeling a
few femurs they put together yeah those
folders those how it was so mad I know
so funny and I got I was running chase I
was writing headcount video there
so there is a clip from Tuesday night's
game between Kansas University in Kansas
State where a fight broke out and it's
going viral just cuz the seem like the
entire team started going at each other
and cheerleaders were trying to help
break up the fight
cheerleaders yeah there were some
cheerleaders that oh yeah thank you Matt
talk
oh wow they're really going at it but I
wonder what Wilma's ask big guys to
somebody's gonna get hurt Jesus Christ
and when you zoom in you can see that
somebody when the players actually
picked up a chair and luckily a coach
grabbed out of his hands last minute
before he was able to discuss a man's
life and another man's freedom as chair
boy it's in like the left corner top
left oh [ __ ] oh the coach grabbed it
yeah Wow what was he
oh my Louis not not thinking he wasn't
thinking
mm-hmm Extreme Rules what what the [ __ ]
were they thinking man I think the one
guy's spent for the whole whole season
won't see this part and that's just a
view that's inside wait oh that's just a
fan though or is that a player looks
like a player from the other bench now
as a woman don't try to break that up
those guys are way too big you know what
I do that big I run the [ __ ] I feel it
is very far out of the way Mill chiller
doing right yep male cheerleader Wow
young dudes Jesus Christ
I guess pants are tired of [ __ ] in the
white yeah it looks like a fan though
huh
well what can you do hmm yeah my buddy
tried to fight a whole frat and he came
at them all one alone and I was the only
I was like hey um this is gonna be a
disaster
do you how are you not doing math do you
have us no he's alone who's like you and
he came at the guys and came at them
started swinging they beat the [ __ ] out
of them they didn't they didn't because
security came and broke it up but he was
he got he came right in at him and I was
like how are you
he goes to me they're just regular dudes
I don't give a [ __ ] I put him in a [ __ ]
and I just I take their clothes off in
my mind and they just look like a naked
[ __ ] huh it's so weird as a gay man
you know who the guys
I was a gay man that's cool you know is
I ran out yeah what else you got okay so
this is another instance where somebody
trying to post something on their fake
Instagram account nothing better on to
their actual account and got caught wear
it so they create it they create an
Instagram account yeah so a lot of
people have a fence tow which is a fake
Instagram and this girl is a contestant
on this season of The Bachelor she is
hot and she posted up this photo after
the episode aired and she went on she
thought that she went onto her fake
Instagram account to leave a comment and
the comment says beautiful date Maddie
you are genuine and real real she forgot
to log out from her old account and
switch to the fake account social media
you got out your social media how about
you but woke up I woke up feeling super
grateful the most perfect date with the
perfect guy heart supposed to get
beautiful day value must be so America
skip bayless got caught with his parole
he's gonna ask you about that
he was like something is true right here
the best man I love everything you do
but he did from his account Kevin Hart
Kevin Garnett got cut too really yep
troll account to me man Kevin Durant
what'd I say Garnett there hey Brad
figments dude really what was he doing I
made that up
when you forget to switch to your fake
fan account you made for yourself
telling your phone make you very
embarrassed oopsie Jesus Christ she must
be like oh do that and there were
shaving cream it's Ezra medicine team at
a true that's a Fanta combo again since
she has fake Instagram account so you
don't know if it's actually her or if
it's actually a fan trying to is it we
don't know we don't know who's posting
those well they're saying her profile
chilling me before we go to Harlem see
how pretty she is
thing the fan was basically saying that
her sister has access to her account and
there's a possibility that her sister
runs the fan account as well and it's
not actually her that could be there
might be something there you know either
way
so embarrassing it's so embarrassed so
embarrassing I mean it says Maddie Pro
right yeah it's much like these pictures
are all give me a good pick-up first one
girls are basically actresses how these
got yeah they're all the lastly they
think this can be their bump to be in
the next [ __ ] Marvel me exactly she's
hot man she is hot let me see what else
you need bikini shot is that her there
how about this one yes she's really hot
oh yeah didn't see the left alright I
like the one on the light I can't talk
yes some meaty legs I'm not mad at that
not mad at that at all look at that with
this there you go girl
oh wow shoes on this - Wow they want to
be on TV super thirsty for the spot yeah
well if you wanna come find kid
ambitious holed up with those her
parents probably know it did my skew
they did the kid from super bad grow up
is that really parents I can't believe
it's a bad best buy a tough picture of
daddies his hands all awkward he's yeah
that he's that stupid shirt yeah he's a
little bit mom would have occurred but
that's good cos that's what they do
right they do those pictures ah that's
her dad hasn't he had the nerd I was
gonna say no he looks like the burnings
of an operation yeah two on a teen you
were too good and then that fake account
girl best year ever
also your friend looks like Jalen now
don't say that I'll see your friendly
face Will Sasso Jay Leno had a bit we're
gonna edit that though because that
split that's a condition the chin
well can we not though she looks like a
true virgin that's wrong with what's
wrong with look like Jay Leno a lie he's
a millionaire
I feel the heat this thought oh the same
thing though you did it and I didn't
have to I had to dress it cuz I didn't
like how she was probably a tough guy
Trevor yeah you know it's right just
angle I would say this angle see what
the caption is 2008 Center one or two
good same yes the same and then her fake
accounts a girl just wait tonight see
that oh come on they're not watching
this time also you think she's like what
the [ __ ] I look like Jay Leno you think
I'm the first one to bring this up yeah
well she did that picture makes her look
probably a little bit like her chins a
little bigger than the other I mean she
actually does look like what we know
those daughter and then going that's
fine don't it that Jen I think she's got
a bow in her hair and that's and and so
I like her bow all right keep going chin
nuzzle that's what we see the resonate
bone does it
what is that bow can we go back for a
second let's go that bows a lot very big
bow like where is that going
it looks like it's connected to her
right I've never seen anybody wrap their
head what's the biggest fall if I don't
it's a Christmas but she is doing is
that's what you'd wrap your present is
that am I wrong
biggest blood that's it that comes in
ribbon that's comes in a ribbon roll the
the wraps her head just being objective
here the biggest ball I've ever seen
biggest chin up if you say so she
wrapped her head at him bow am I wrong I
don't know there's your chin a very
sweet girl yes very very cool gotta
[ __ ] she's on The Price is Right huh
mmm-hmm come on down what's what their
mom moms moms a cutie pie yeah I'll
trusty that dad again where's that dork
of a dad let's not make fun of my dad's
dorky yeah well here he is if you want
to see him again
what's the door just dude there's
nothing wrong you know I'm gonna make a
call dad looks like a very tall like X
golf pro or something no no no dad looks
just like that guy with strollers I'm
the young kid from super vets I see
Michael Cera
girl he looks like my Sarah elixir he
looks like an older Michael Cera yeah he
looked in all my could say he's i
spot-on
yeah oh and they're holding that girl
with those jeans then you were you know
I don't wear holey jeans you don't and
I've also let skinny jeans are out dude
my boy Frank Grillo I don't care he has
holes on them uh he won't like he's
raising Badgers Yeah right
hey Frank I know you watch show kid wear
those he had his jeans are not in
fashioning you're older than I am now
let's go
can't do it we can't do it yeah what's a
real picture Jim why would you feel that
there's let's get off her I don't care
about her anymore
oh there's one last one with your dad
that's sweet one that's cute that's cute
though just homecoming queen mm-hmm
that's cute well she's got a good family
all right she's a doll
oh there's their fake account again girl
this is check the begin for you what
else you got oh it's me I'm sure you
guys heard about this already the
mountain lion attack on a three year old
boy weird it's in a lake forest
it's a wildlife parking we click first
in Orange County
holy [ __ ] rain tracers in Lake Forest
yep
children and you know six-year-old was
that was hiking with her parents in
Colorado yeah mountain lion came down
grabbed a child and disappeared they
never saw a child lucky for this one the
dad caught it in time so there was take
a child and take yes well you know what
I don't know where I live there's a like
a it's like a dog park to the beginning
of a walking trail and there's signs all
over please keep your toes posted
mountain lions and other snakes don't
[ __ ] around with no crowds not safe in
mountain lion hold hands
Taiyo ds2 coyotes if they're alone yeah
you don't want to [ __ ] around with that
but especially mountain lions mountain
lions well children will get eaten by
Maduro when that mountain lion ate those
bikers yeah that I think is in
Washington right what happened attack
the bike they attacked the bikers and
then they attacked one and then the one
friend was like oh [ __ ] dude good luck
I'm gonna good help ran away mountain
lions like where the [ __ ] you going
dumbass ate him alive
Oh killed him and all they found was the
skull white he dragged the whole body up
to the thing they found the guys to go I
didn't know that they killed something
like that it was something like that
really exactly
there's a mountain line they filled the
mountain for doing mountain lion [ __ ]
yeah though only the best part is the
one guy who ditch this room yeah that's
the food good luck bro we gonna get help
he killed that guy got killed the other
guy survived Jesus because cuz he ran
away in the mountain lion go yeah yeah
and then the best ride they were best
friends and they found out his friend
was a piece of [ __ ] cuz gonna leave him
to die and then he had to do that press
conference me like you know Jerry was
brave and a trustworthy friend but you
just tell you [ __ ] they said a mountain
lion can jump the length of a bus that's
a long death a lot well I don't know
because I saw a tiger do that that's you
ever see a tight you ever see a tiger
attack the guy on the he just keeps
flying
yeah just keeps going sorry yeah yeah it
is it is out for what in the yeah bound
up to 40 feet running leap 15 feet up a
tree climb over a 12 foot fellow no they
they're crazy they can jump 12-foot
fence well then so there was a photonic
in amount line jump over a bus for me
the length of of us the length of a bus
so no they not saying they jump over a
bus they can jump 45 feet horizontally
over is crazy
bust a long way though that's what says
this means they can jump over a school
bus the long way that says is if you
actually believe this you're an idiot
well no wait come on yeah unread so in
other words they can't start at down the
floor and jump over that's how a Dave
right but if they were running a long
jump they can they can cover that much
distance maybe that seems a long ways
you include your 20 yeah right 23 but
also [ __ ] not mine you've been [ __ ]
animal killing kids and [ __ ] yeah we
don't need him around joke I'm everyone
was all up in arms when we got hit on
the 405 apex predators but they leave
people alone they're really shy yeah
yeah but they was it's very rare yeah
your kid you know so when that one got
hit on the 405 thing but a very similar
I'm trying to cross the [ __ ] smoke my
life is hiking three years old though
that's like tiger baby oh dude Tigers
big yeah alright [ __ ] mountain life
with you grab them by the neck and start
dragging away the Lord the father caught
in time through a backpack at him and
then he took the backpack and took out
of a tree that's what you see in the
back over here so they're pretty damn
sure this is the cat so they found the
authorities and they killed them
gotta kill me yeah shoot me right in the
face
shoot them out my [ __ ] you you're not in
danger now they're thriving out here
yeah that's why when you hit one in the
405 that should give you [ __ ] bonus
points they're everywhere those stupid
things you know they're gonna make a
crosswalk yeah
from it's from Santa Monica to like
Brentwood well because they had to cross
the highways yeah but they didn't make
it
yeah so now they fight they try cross
the 405 you know here's a could be
pro-science could also save your life if
you do see one on the 405 or a moose you
know you don't slow down
you know why you speed up absolutely go
over the roof not through that's right
interesting so if you see a mount lying
fussing beed the [ __ ] up try to hit it
yeah try it well hit it in the air speed
speed I got a Tesla though I got a low
low no we'll see you about my Porsche
man is it 12:00 at night is that van
it's solely wonder wrestle for [ __ ]
no late it's almost 7:00 dude
give us one more more [ __ ] I did well
this time I think all right this is a
the headline looks pretty crazy right
says Mike Tyson reveals disturbing
details about his children's hatred
toward African Americans but what he
means is he was on TI's podcasts and
what he means is his daughter's date all
white guys and they think he thinks it's
his fault because when they're growing
up they're afraid of their own dad
because he's so you know file and crazy
so it was his mistake as a parent that
made daughters a crime in a very
affluent area that's mostly white dot
too and that she grew up in white
schools and so she's doing that too I
don't know did you see Serena Williams
hitting a heavy bag she's with best
tennis player ever in the st. athlete
but when you see her hitting yes she
looks on it she looks terrible
yeah a good player see Steve Naismith
doughnuts terrible weight this is Serena
yeah watch this it's not great now she's
a great she's a great athlete but she
doesn't know yeah look now if you taught
her that's so they thought if she would
be a [ __ ] out of you wait wait why
you're [ __ ] this is Mike Tyson join
us oh but where's uh where's the quote
about his daughters but also some some
white guys are awesome giving [ __ ] these
what guess my kids are my black is they
don't
why is that it's nice like I'm a better
at a white guys and I think I didn't set
a good example as a black man then they
must have seen me sometimes when I was
vulnerable and said hey I don't want to
be with no one like that he's scary
that's fair
yeah that's all but I'm in the head like
somebody himself he's talking about
himself yeah yeah I think you're right
where they grew up maybe some bomb-ass
why dude yeah it's girl for me chance to
go over to the this way yes keeps
rolling up no keep going yes here you
will cannot miss her keep keep keep
going there we go there we go Oh Russell
Simmons ninth year old daughter Ming Lee
crutches Instagram Jesus Christ what a
[ __ ] smoke show and his other
daughter is 16 and she just got into
Harvard he had some issues Russell
Simmons hey somebody to movement there
yeah he did have something like that
after his daughter's dresser damn she's
gorgeous
mmm-hmm God - painfully honest know what
I adore is not shoes I hear those aren't
her shoes how do you know well don't do
that oh whoa this got dark that's I
think that's her mom's branch some
shitty facts warned her out yeah her mom
yeah her mom was the one who created
baby fat and add they're doing a revamp
so oh that's depressing what the [ __ ]
they're doing now her daughter is the
face you're gone does it for these
pictures what a smoke show
what a [ __ ] smoke show good current
event guys what else you guys got that
was it right that's last one yeah that's
[ __ ] it oh wait
Nick Cannon that guy said he sucked his
dick huh now what what oh god you guys
are so old where who this guy came out
said uh Orlando Brown he used to be on
that So Raven yeah brother
That's So Raven what's that Turkey
that's his thing yeah that's his thing
servant yeah he's not doing anymore is
he the turban thing what does Nick
Cannon do he's a name of show he hosts
it yeah he's a house today Michelle and
he's the voice are that he's the head DJ
he's a Mario Lopez he's like uh Mario
there you go
the more he turned in the Mario Lopez
yeah alright but apparently this you
well you know he's older Nick Nick looks
like easiness delayed importance yeah he
was he used to own a bunch of radio
shacks let me see in a video that went
viral brown best known for his roles as
major pain and that's so raven that
means things aren't going well talk
about letting Nick perform oral sex on
that means Nick's artistic this clip was
eventually posted on the shade room
called out in a cannon
after a few media outlets picked up the
story can react on social media he said
my first thoughts I thought it was
[ __ ] hilarious but then after put a
little cognitive effort and analytical
thought to the situation I figured what
a great opportunity for a teachable
moment can and continue first off let me
see I'm praying for the young brother
Orlando even though I don't really know
him personally I've always loved enjoyed
his talent I've been a fan of his past
work we better support Safari okay well
this alright
yeah he's Brown was also arrested for
battery after police found a family
disturbance for instead of hauled off on
a drug charges for resisting arrest
instructing a public officer he was
arrested for burglary during a bizarre
interview with dr. Phil that September
the child actor admitted to drinking a
lot heavily medicating with marijuana
and taking the crystal meth so yeah he's
saying how this guy's Johnny could have
right off the Sun set off the [ __ ]
wage of that So Raven That's So Raven
remember her mo surname live racism
mount Raven Symone he's okay one more
time gay woman is she yeah you don't say
yeah she came out a while ago right
Raven he's a sweet guy she was on TV or
host she's out let's talk yeah that
thinks something like that way event
then like Whoopi Goldberg like fights
everybody off that's another one another
show will be goldberg view the view yeah
i know they're both on the view okay and
then they would fight like two Siamese
fish yeah you say about Cleveland boomer
the boomers gonna be in Cleveland OH
brings out pal boomer how many nicknames
okay out how long gay Gale rinks Boomer
jockey sweetheart formats
John I don't like any of those a ring
stick neck man dragon no no man dragon
haven [ __ ] bring your fire retarding
this scrotum that generate 34:31 10/10
fat one and then West Palm Beach
February 14 15 16 let's go ah sore I'm
in Charlotte this Thursday Friday
Saturday the coffee zone next week
Columbus Ohio the place called Columbus
Ohio funny bone funny bones funny bones
Columbus Ohio next week 31st through
February 1st and then February 6th
through the 8th I'm in San Antonio
then Ontario Valentine's Day come make
out get your tits out Ontario California
that's the 13th through the 15th
one-night-only Vancouver at the vogue
Theatre for Just for Laughs comedy
festival get your tickets now
Tacoma Chicago Atlanta New Orleans also
on sale get up t5k calm Charlotte this
weekend anything else Jacque that's it
buddy
all right Jackie well I did pretty well
rustling compliment my [ __ ] stand up
nope how's your hand I my hands for
showing that me I would I could I would
gotta be honest me I got I got to be
honest you break your hand hey hey I
gotta be honest with you [ __ ]
listen up hey Jackie listen [ __ ]
I gotta be honest with you I'm scrotum
now I'm happy I'm liking my chances cuz
I'm gonna tell you something I'm
figuring you out a little bit
are you yeah you have tendencies so I'm
gonna see some openings and I'm gonna
I'm gonna surprise you I'm just gonna
keep training and make a nice try pin
you down on Botox your neck my neck is
not bad look at chins like it's not not
chin call me is your neck is
Chin's full of [ __ ] and I was like thank
you buddy
well when I'm turned this way you're
gonna [ __ ] see a little bit dude you
and Clint Eastwood have the same neck so
it's not you like you're not true
now I have tuberculosis for my wrestling
match Wow where are you going what are
you doing what you mean dewd gonna show
huh
no no trap what time you're going to
charlatan my flights at 7:00 a.m. what
is this man I'm just checking things out
all right dude Sharla huh
let me ask you this direct flight or you
gotta take a connection come on daddy
only flies drive oh man dude I'm out of
here man leave me alone
this is a bunch in on out